et has lured Gabrielle's firing from a
GT has sparked an investigation by the
SAG after Union and NBC just issued a
second statement on the controversy
quote we are working with MS Union
through her representatives to hear more
about her concerns and more details are
coming out one report claims that Union
was labeled as difficult by Simon Cowell
and producers when she complained about
Simon's smoking inside the theater where
agt is filmed add that to the original
claims that before she was fired
gabrielle complained about a toxic
culture on the AG tea set she was
reportedly told several times that her
hairstyles were quote too black and
she's got celebrity support ariana
grande tweeted we're with you Grey's
Anatomy star Ellen Pompeo wrote it's
unfortunate that NBC the same network
that protected disgusting men like Matt
Lauer and punished women for speaking
out has not changed their practices or
culture and will in Grace's Debra
Messing slammed NBC quote this is
disgusting behavior from a network that
has been my professional home for
decades Gabriele tweeted thanks for the
love so many tears so much gratitude
just when you feel lost adrift alone you
got me up off the ground
[Music]